Hello my name is Alexandria Economou and I'm going to have a conversation
with Alex Catti for Visible Lives An Oral History Project at
the New York Public Library.
It is February 8th, 2015
and this is being recorded in my home: Mountaintown, New York.
Hi, Alex.
Hi.
Can tell you a bit about where you grew up? Sure, I grew up in a suburban town in New York.
New York. It was a very Irish population. And me, being Italian, felt a little
bit out of place. But, uh, that was a nice place.
[Hard cut, missing audio.]--primarily upper middle class. Um. And
town of about fifteen thousand people.
[Inaudible.]
You remember your first encounter or earliest encounter with somebody who
had some kind of disability? Yes.
Yes. There was a student in one of my classes in elementary school, and I
believe he had cerebral palsy. Um. But he always was very
very well liked. He had friends in school. Um. And
he always seemed to be having a good time. I mean, we all hung out together.
How did that make you feel? [Alex:] It was good to see that our class
classmates accepted him, and didn't treat him differently just because he had
um, a disability that made him, um,
like act differently from us, uh-a-and I-don't-mean act differently in a physical way. But it didn't
change the fact that people still wanted to talk to him. They wanted to be friends with him. So I
was happy to see that. That's good.
So, in high school, you had a friend that had a kidney transplant and
somebody who was going through something quite different. Um.
You weren't put off in any way.
Why is that? Because I realize that everybody, including myself
has certain struggles that we have to face in our lives, and there's
nothing to say that one person's struggle is better or
worse, more uncomfortable than someone else's. It's just things that they have to deal with but
it doesn't make them a different person.
And then.
That friend introduced you to somebody else who had a transplant. Me.
And, how did we even become friends?
I remember that I think she introduced us on AIM when AIM was
popular. [Alex laughs in the background: "Oh, yeah!") So I find that funny how it's changed since then
But I remember we were talking, and maybe it was a snow day or something and we just kept talking online
and we just became friends that way. And then, I think the
first time we came, we hung out, was when he came to see one of the plays that I was working on.
Yeah, I remember that. So because of lovely
technology our friendship started. Yeah.
Yup. Exactly.
We've been friends for about seven years, but it feels so much longer.
I think because you never judged me.
You know, I mean, you made me feel okay. What's your take on it? I
I didn't judge you because I don't, I never saw you any differently than I saw
anybody else.
I mean, we're all people. So I'm happy that our friendship started
so strong and it's lasted for this time. And you're right! It does feel longer because we've
been through so much. High school. College! [Alexandria:] Yeah, and other things! [Alex:] Yeah, and we've
seen so many, many shows [Yeah] and done a lot
[Room tone.]
Do you ever feel uncomfortable? Or, like, you didn't know the right thing to say to
me?
(Slight pause.) No. I think I always,
I've always known what to say. I mean, you just talk to your friends...
that's just it. You just talk to your friends. And, um. Sometimes it's hard to
think of what to say to people in general. Like, if people are going through a bad break up, or there's something
you know that they need help with. Sometimes you don't know how to console them if you've never been
through it before. But sometimes there's not much you can do other than just listen to them
and hear them out when they're stressed, and be there for them if they if they need your
support.
Yes I agree.
Like, you know, here's a good example. When I was having -  going to have -
another surgery.  How did that make you feel.
I was worried for you but I knew that you've been, you were strong,
strong. You are strong and that you weren't going to have a problem getting through it because you've gotten through
everything up until that point. [Alexandria:] Yes. (Sound of pages turning.)
(Silence.)
Were you scared with me? I think a little bit, but I didn't know... I
think it's a different kind of scared because you don't know what it feels like to
be the person going through it. You can only see it from an outside lens.
So you hope that everything is going to go well but it's not your
own. Um. It's not your own experience.
So it's a little bit different.  But even though it wasn't your own experience
you lived it vicariously through me and... Yes.
For sure. And how did that feel?  I remember, I think you were, it was either
before you went in, or whatnot, you had said that you were kind of nervous and that your
mom was like trying to calm you down or whatever and I just remember thinking I couldn't imagine
what I would be like. I'd probably be doing the same thing. Freaking out, like oh my gosh ,I don't know if I can
do this, but, um.  Yeah, I don't know, I just
I think that one moment kind of put it in perspective for me because I figured I'd be acting the
same way that were so...Wow
OK. So you know, I never really thought of this
this way but, I guess, you know, for our friendship to continue
you had to come to terms with the fact that, you know, I
am disabled. I have medical stuff and this was kind of my existence.
Um.
What do you think, or how did that make you feel? I mean, it didn't make me
feel anything different.  We still do things that everybody else
everybody else would do as two friends.  It's just that maybe I'll be the one driving all the time and you might not
be but you know, that's OK. [Laughs. ]We work around the things that you might have a little bit
more difficulty doing and we get, we do, whatever we want to do anyway.
Yeah. Yeah, that is true. Sometimes you have to be creative. Yeah.
I always felt that you had empathy towards me.
I've seen you have it with others. Are you aware this? I guess
At a subconcious level I'm aware of it.  I think it's because like I was saying before
before, we all have struggles that we're dealing with and I know that I have my own
personal things that I am trying to work through, and sometimes still am trying to work through. So
even if I'm not going through the same thing as someone else, even if it's something completely different that I've never had to deal with,
I understand that it might be tough for that person and that maybe they need
someone to... to be their friend and to listen to them and
sometimes that listening, it helps. It helps for people to vent, and it helps for people to
to know that someone does care even if they don't, um, have that same exact
experience.
Yes.
Given all that you know about my medical condition. What
has surprised you about me?
I think you are... Resiliency. When there's a
problem the way that you're able to, you're able to go to the
doctor and, and get all these shots and whatnot. It doesn't faze you.
. But also just the way they never let it stop you from doing what you want and you work
on your ceramics and I think that's really cool. So not a lot of people do that. You never let it stop you from
being creative in trying to work in the theater. You graduated college.
Like all these things that people, I think, don't really realize that people with a
disability are a hundred percent capable of doing - more than a hundred percent capable of doing  - and I
think that before we were friends I never really thought about it.
But then after seeing all you can do I realized, like, anybody can do anything.
You can. You really can.
Are you able to learn from somebody who has to do things so differently from yourself?
.
Yes, and I think as a teacher, which is what I do,
that you have to be open to learning to how, learning how other
people do things because you can, you can see a lot
of different perspectives and maybe it'll give you some idea on how to manage something in
your own life.  Maybe in a way you've never thought of before.  Maybe you'll see a new perspective
never thought of before. So. We have to we have to learn from others. Otherwise we would
be closed off and we wouldn't really go anywhere as individuals or as a society.
I think,
You know, life in general is a whole learning experience. Absolutely. I
believe that we're learning from the time we're born until the time we die. Yes.
Has knowing me changed your perspective on
disability? In any particular way?
I guess any perceptions you had before knowing me
in the years that you have known me?
Yeah, I think that, like I was saying a couple minutes ago, that I never
really thought about people with disabilities. Um, it, you know,
very explicitly. Except maybe that one classmate that I
that I was with. But he never let anything stop him from doing
anything and when I saw him making friends and running around the track with the rest of us
even though it was a little bit harder for him, I've said or realized that anybody can do anything, and then when
we became friends I didn't really question it. I didn't really think that maybe there were things
that you couldn't do or, or weren't capable of doing because really you don't let things
get you down. So, I guess I saw that disability... maybe it
makes things more difficult in one way but it doesn't stop people from being who they are
and getting things done that they want to do.
You know, just sometimes I may have to do it in a different way just doesn't mean I can't.
Exactly.
Just I have to find a different way.
Do you ever feel compelled to help somebody with an obvious disability because
you know me?
Yes, and I don't know if it's because I know you or maybe it's just my
nature, but in one of my jobs, we have patrons that come into the
theater and sometimes they're in wheelchairs or they have walkers or canes
and you know, I... it's just knowing that they need someone to
to maybe clear the path for them and get them down to their stage level seating. It's little
things and they they really do appreciate it when someone understands that maybe they need a little
bit of extra help. And then as a teacher I have some students who have
some, um, you know, IEPs.
And again, it's just knowing that... having some, um.
What kind of modifications they need, and just helping them. And they really appreciate it. You can see how... how
well they do once you  take the time out to... to make the appropriate modifications.
So just giving someone that little extra hand goes a long way. So do you
feel or notice that you actually go out of your way to help
people that you know have an obvious disability?
I... I don't really consider it going out of my way. I would just consider it being
a good person doing the right thing. I think going out of your way implies
that it's a bother, a burden. Which it shouldn't be. We should just help each
other. That's the way it's supposed to be. Then maybe I said that the wrong way and
Please edit this out maybe.
Not even that you go out of your way. You know, just, you have that whole, that
feeling that you want to help more.
Oh. Yes. I think so. Because I want to make...I want to make
someone's day enjoyable. I want someone to realize that there
are good people out there. Because a lot of the time I think people will turn a blind eye and I definitely don't want to
be that person, because, hey, we're all people and you never know what's going to happen to you in
your life and you want to make someone else enjoy themselves and
you want them to have a good experience because you hope someone would do the same for you.
So true and
You know. What disability they they truly know when you're
being sincere or you're faking it you know you've always been sincere
thank you. I think also you're OK to help
other people in this case of no meat you feel like an insider
.
Yes and you get you get it you just get it.
Yeah because even those people that have different abilities it's just knowing that sometimes you have
to get over it.
So if you have personal experiences with
people who have had difficult journeys
what would you want what would you say on their behalf to the world outside of the
civility and I would say don't judge.
And that might sound really obvious but it's true because
they just fear that a lot of people have is the judgment of others
. And what will people say and what are they going to think and that's really a
paralyzing fear for a lot of people that I've seen but the strongest people are the ones
that say you know what people are going to judge me and I can't do anything about it so I'm just going to do what I
need to do and move on. But the thing is it's sad that it
has to be like that and it's sad that people will always judge
I should say will be judged hopefully it'll change but people do judge so harshly.
So I think my biggest message to the people who
don't necessarily deal with disability is. I
don't I don't judge really. Because you don't know how much you can you can
hurt someone without even realizing it.
And Alex for my final question. Any words of wisdom
.
I would say try as as a person in
society just try to learn from others and
hear other people's stories and hear their experiences because that will give
you such a good well rounded view of
what life is like for not only yourself the people that you're close to but you learn
so many other things and maybe from learning something else you'll get to meet new people and make new
friends that you never thought you would have. For I know that from working in search in different
jobs and and taking on different interests I met friends from all different walks
and I think that that's so interesting and so fun because
life isn't black and white there are so many different things in between
. So you should try to learn as much as you can as
I tend to say I would agree. I don't really know about the black and
white.
That's true. Yeah. So that's what I would say is that
the best thing to do and just as a general thing you know it's
good in.
That it is the end of our conversation. Thank you so much, Alex. Thanks for having me.
me.